So let's see now if we can design a better search tree for Bob and Carol as well
so that they also can look happy.
As you'll remember, Bob was working on the clique problem,
finding a set of vertices in a graph that all were connected as much as possible,
so a set something like this. All vertices are connected to all other vertices.
And Carol was looking for the opposite thing, so a number of vertices
that were not connected to each other at all in a network.
So I'm going to draw this dashed line here to show that there's no connection.
We're actually going just to look at independent set
because as you'll remember, clique and independent set are so closely connected
that it's actually once you have an algorithm for independent set,
it's not that difficult to design a very similar algorithm for clique.
You can basically use the same techniques.
So in order to design a good search tree for Carol, how do we design this?
Actually, it's quite similar to vertex cover.
Remember how we defined an independent set.
In an independent set, no 2 vertices can be connected to each other.
We can actually play the same game that we played for vertex cover in a search tree.
So let's say you have 2 vertices, and we're going to call this one here v and this one u,
and the 2 vertices are connected by an edge,
and we're now trying to assign values of 0 and 1 to those vertices.
So 1 and 0 here, 1 and 0 here, same as for vertex cover,
only this time we are looking at assignments that would be valid for independent set
as opposed to vertex cover.